[Music]
hello everyone i'm chad from autel
diagnostics i'm the national sales
manager for strategic accounts
and we're going to focus on the im508
in this training so the im 508 we're
going to talk about the setup
we're going to talk about how to do the
updates on the tool we're going to talk
about getting scan reports
key programming some helpful resources
and
what is the key programmer and how do we
use it
so the im508 is based off of an
android tablet so the android tablet
does have diagnostics
and key programming built into the tool
we do have limited
app access to the device so autel really
limits
the apps that you can add onto this
android device
and we do that because there are so many
apps that will interfere with the maxi
im
software that we really wanted to limit
what was put onto the tool
we really recommend that you don't put
any apps on the tool but there are some
basic apps that you can use if you want
some key programming resources apps
or something along those lines those can
be loaded if you want to
so you'll see here on the screen we do
have two different parts that we're
mainly going to focus on this is our key
programming device here on the left
and then we do have our android tablet
so right off we're going to talk about
making sure that your tablet
is current and up to date and we want to
do this pretty much
every day just to make sure we always
have the latest and greatest software
when it comes to when it comes to
software
autel releases new updates almost every
week
and we want to make sure that you always
have the most
current and relevant software and autel
understands that
sometimes the the diagnostic software
that's released is not perfect
and we want to know about that if
there's an issue we want to know so we
can fix it
and then re-release it so those updates
are kind of come out
weekly so make sure that you check for
updates that are available
and we let you know that updates are
available by giving you a number
on top of that icon so if we look down
here in the bottom right corner
you'll see settings and update and we
can see that in the
settings icon we have one update
available if we look at the updates icon
we have 24. so let's go ahead and focus
on the settings one first
so if we go into settings you're going
to see on the left hand side
that we have a firmware upgrade where
that number one icon is
so that firmware upgrade is going to be
able to upgrade
the background of the tool that's going
to upgrade the android platform that's
going to
upgrade the maxi im platform so all that
stuff is going to be done
in that firmware upgrade and to be able
to do that
we'll just select that firmware upgrade
and you will see that
the update status shows up we do need to
be connected to wi-fi to be able to
retrieve these updates and see the
newest updates that are available
you can see here that currently this
tool is at version 1.5 and our latest
version
is 2.0 so quite a big jump when it comes
to firmware updates and then we just
select that update now button
and it will tell us that we need to
connect to the vehicle we need to
connect the obd2 cord
directly to the ob2 port and leave it
there while we do this update we do not
want to disconnect that
this update goes pretty fast it doesn't
take a lot of time but
make sure we have a stable internet
connection and that we are connected to
the vehicle
at all times so once that's done we'll
just go back to the main screen
by pushing the back button that m here
the house in the middle of it
or we can use the back button down here
at the bottom you'll notice with this
tool there's always multiple ways to
navigate
so you can use whichever is most
convenient for you
if we go back to the maxi im screen and
we'll focus on that update button the
update button shows us that we have
24 updates that are available now you
don't have to do every update that is
available on these tools sometimes
you'll get updates for vehicles that you
may not need
so it is totally up to you as far as
what updates you want to perform
we're going to start out always with a
system update if a system update is
available
you must first do that system update
before you can do any vehicle line
updates and sometimes what we will see
is that that system update will hide
other updates that are available so you
may go in and say
oh the only update is a system update no
big deal i don't want to do that right
now
but once you do that system update you
may have a bunch of vehicle updates
behind that
so i always recommend making sure that
you get those system updates done as
quickly as possible and you'll notice
that we tell you what that system update
is on this particular
one we're optimizing a payment function
that we're going to talk about
here in a moment as well to be able to
do that update it's a simple process
we just select that green down arrow and
that will start downloading
that update this speed is going to
depend on your internet connection
uh and some of these can be pretty large
files if you look over on the left hand
side
we tell you how large that file is so if
you're working on a hotspot
do consider that as well once we get our
system updates done
it will go into the vehicle updates and
you can see that this one is showing a
volkswagen update
and if you look at the top of the screen
right here in the center you'll notice
there's two different sides of the tool
there's the immobilizer side and the
diagnostics
side so each one is going to have their
own updates
for key programming or for diagnostics
right now
we're under the diagnostics tab and you
can see that this volkswagen has an
update available
if we look here on the middle you can
see that it's going to be a
basic snapshot of what this update is
and we're going to support
all volkswagen models up to 2020 in this
update
but if you want more information because
a lot of times there's a bunch of
information behind this
that will pull up more information about
this update so you can see all the
information in that update
and all the ins and outs of what has
been added
by just selecting that information icon
we'll go back to the maxi im screen our
next one we're going to focus on
is service so i talked about this being
based on the mx808 chassis from autel
and that
tool is a service tool so that gives us
the ability to do
oil life resets electronic parking brake
battery management resets
and more and this may be a function that
you would use every day but it is great
to have
if necessary especially the battery
management system
if a customer has replaced a battery in
that vehicle that you're getting ready
to work on and they've
not redone that battery management
system or updated the battery management
this gives you the opportunity to do
that before you do
any key programming tasks so these
service functions are available for you
if you need them
if you see a need in the field
our next step we're going to focus on is
the diagnostics
side of the tool and the diagnostics on
this tool are going to be
the ability to read and clear codes in
all modules
gather live data and do graphing there's
no bi-directional controls in this tool
as far as diagnostics go
so let's go ahead and jump in and see
what this looks like
when we go onto the diagnostic screen
you're going to see all the different
manufacturers that you can select from
and you can break it down into u.s
european
and asian if you want to you'll notice
that you have these
green down arrows on some of the
manufacturers
and that means that there's an update
available so even before you go into a
manufacturer if you see that down arrow
on a chrysler you may want to do the
updates before performing diagnostics on
that vehicle so we can have
the latest and greatest software you'll
notice that chrysler dodge and jeep are
all highlighted
and that's because they're all contained
into one download and we also have ford
and
ob2 that we can do updates on
whenever we were ready to go into a
vehicle if it is a 2006
or newer we can use auto vin that's here
in the top left corner
what we'll do is we'll just select auto
and we'll let the tool do all the hard
work
no need to select year make model the
tool will actually pull the vin
out of the vehicle and give us that vin
number off of the car here's their vin
number
automatically pulled we'll select ok and
that will tell us
the year make and model of the car so
this is a 2015
chevy volt and if we would scroll down
it would give us engine information
and all that there as well
so why why are we doing diagnostics why
are we giving you
diagnostics in a key programming tool
well
there's a couple of key things that we
can use from this
diagnostic side of the tool and the
first one
is to keep yourself out of trouble if we
go to a vehicle
and even before we cut any keys or do
anything with this vehicle we can do
what's called a pre-scan
and a pre-scanners gives us the ability
to scan this vehicle for codes
we can look through the vehicle and make
sure that there are no codes that
pertain to what we're doing as far as
the key programming side of the tool
goes
so we can do a pre-scan we can get all
the code information
out of that vehicle first before we do
anything
as far as the keys going here's why
emphasize that
because as a key programmer as a
locksmith
if you touch that vehicle everything
after that point
is your fault and
unfortunately in this industry people
say oh it wasn't that way before you put
the keys in it
so this gives us the ability to cover
ourselves and
do that pre-scan report we can print
that report out and we can take that to
the service writer or the customer and
say hey mr customer just so you know
you have some other things going on here
that you may need to address before
i do this vehicle you have abs codes you
have airbot
module codes you have all these codes i
didn't do those
i'm just letting you know that you have
them would you like me to proceed
they can sign off on that and you can go
about programming the keys to that
vehicle
we can also do a post scan a post scan
is scanning for codes
after you're done programming keys so
did we have to take stuff apart did we
have to unplug
modules in the process did we set any
codes
in that vehicle this gives us the
ability to
scan that vehicle clear any codes out
that we created
and then go about finishing the key
programming process
and giving that customer the invoice so
we can read and clear codes in this
vehicle we can do
active tests and special functions under
that
service icon only none under the
diagnostic side so you see here just
some of the basic screens where we're
talking about
the diagnostics and we'll go through
those here in a moment
so let's talk about what does it look
like so once we've auto vend that
vehicle we can select
diagnose and that will take us into our
option of auto scan or control unit
and you can go either way depending on
what you're trying to do with the car if
we select control unit
that's going to take us into every
module possible for that vehicle
so doesn't mean it necessarily has that
module it just
could be in that car from the factory so
we may select
a module that this vehicle does not have
so if i was to select
electronic power seats in this vehicle
it would say no communication because
this car does not have that
but if you know exactly where you need
to go you can jump right into that
module and do what i call quick and
dirty
and jump right in and get the
information you need if we go back and
we select
auto scan what that's going to do is
it's going to go through
every module in that car it's going to
talk to that module and say
are you here and do you have any codes
and it's going to go through that
complete vehicle
and tell you any modules that have codes
now that we've done a complete auto scan
on this car you can see that the engine
control module does have
one code in it at the bottom of the
screen you'll see a button that says
reports
this report icon gives us the ability to
see a
total health picture of that car so by
selecting report it will automatically
generate a report that shows all the
modules and any codes that are in those
modules
from there as well we'll be able to
print that report to hand it to a
customer
if necessary or that we can keep it off
to the side and use that to put our
notes onto and i'll show you how to
print here
at the end of the presentation so just
remember that that report icon is there
to make your life a little bit easier
especially if the vehicle has a lot of
codes in it
we can see all the codes in it and if
all those codes are pertaining to
what we're doing in this key programming
session
if we want to go in and see exactly what
that code is in this engine control
module
we can select this little blue carrot
here on the right hand side of the tool
so if we select that it's going to take
us into our options menu
for ecu information trouble codes and
live data
so ecu information that is going to be
the information about that module
what is the current calibration id what
is the vin number in that module and
that is important to you
because if a customer is swapping
modules
let's say a body control module on a
ford and
you were there to program keys back to
that vehicle did they program the vin
back to that module this gives us the
ability to make sure that our vins
match if we have any trouble in the key
programming session
we can also go to trouble codes and see
exactly what that trouble code is so if
we select trouble code
that'll take us into any codes that are
in there this is going to give us
current pending or history or past codes
you can see on this particular car we
have a p0531 this is an ac refrigerant
pressure code
now this doesn't pertain to our key
programming session but
if you wanted to know more about this
code this little icon here on the side
that looks like a snowflake that is
freeze frame data so that gives us
information about
what exact conditions were happening
when this code was set
if we select that it's going to take us
into that data this is frozen data
so it's not live this is information
that happened exactly when that code was
set and
what was going on during that session
so we can look at this and we can say
that this code was set
almost 1400 miles ago
so it is definitely not a current code
it's something that happens
1400 miles ago so it's not something we
have to focus on
right now to be able to do our
programming session
but we can also see some of the
statistics that were set during that
time so we know the engine was warmed up
it was 100 degrees
and some of the other information if we
focus down on those
now this is important to us in the key
programming session because if we have a
code for a
let's say an antenna inside the car we
know how long that antenna's been out
or if it's continuing to go out if it's
a current code if that antenna is
already
out or not been plugged back in it's not
going to let us program keys
so we need to know that information
before we move forward so that's where
we can find that
information we can also go into
live data and when we select live data
in that module you'll see that this car
has an option for immobilizer data
and this is actually in the hybrid
control module on this chevy volt we're
going to select
immobilizer and that will take us into
the live data of what the car is seeing
at this
moment so if we look at the live data
presented in this immobilizer module
you'll see that we have immobilizer
environment
device what are those
well those are actually the antenna for
the proximity key
and if we look the value of those it
shows that those are
all okay if those are not okay
then we are going to have an issue with
an antenna and the key is not going to
program
how is it supposed to know if the key is
inside the vehicle or outside the
vehicle
if an antenna is not working so we need
to make sure that those
are functioning as well and usually
those are going to set a code right away
so we can kind of break that down and
figure out which antenna has the issue
which one do they leave unplugged after
they took this whole vehicle apart and
put it back together
if we scroll down a little bit more
you'll notice that we have the
immobilizer
system status so in this particular car
at this particular moment
i have the ignition off but i have the
accessories
on so you'll see that showing that it is
currently in
standby mode so if we want to
go ahead and back out of this if we're
all done
we can select that back arrow and that
will take us out so it's going to ask us
are you done are you sure
you want to get out of here we'll select
yes now to get completely out of this
vehicle we're going to
select this icon up here at the top
where these two cars are then arrowed
down
and that is going to take us all the way
back to the beginning to the maxi im
screen and that is how you exit a
vehicle so if you are pretty deep into a
vehicle you don't have to push that back
button 10 times
you can just push those cars with the
arrow pointing down
and that will take us all the way back
to the maxi im screen and out of
diagnostics
you cannot transition from diagnostics
to immobilizer
you have to back all the way out every
time to go from one side to the other
they are two completely different
softwares in the tool
so we have to make sure we back all the
way out and that car icon going down is
the easiest way to do that
so let's talk about some of the hardware
in the tool and let's talk about
specifically the key programmer this is
the
xp200 this comes in your im508 device
so there's a couple different things
that this tool does it does a couple of
fancy things and a couple of not so
fancy things
and first is going to be to test and
identify keys and that's what we're
going to go through
it can perform ee prom functions so if
we have a vehicle that we need to access
that chip to be able to pull the pin
information out
we can do that from this tool and that
right here if you look on the side of
the tool there's a little com port
there are boards that fit into the side
of that com port to give us the eeprom
access so we can actually remove chips
do in circuit out of circuit eeprom
functionality on a basic level
for our asian and domestic vehicles this
is where we can also do our pre-coding
of keys if our
vehicle that we're working on does not
have a slot
in it for recognizing the keys no key
slot we can
perform the pre-code of the keys with
this tool as well
it may also be used as a security device
so anytime the tool asks you please plug
in programmer
we're asking you to plug in that usb
cable into your programmer and it
actually just uses that as a secondary
authentication device for some of the
server
functionality that we're doing so
just keep an eye on that if the tool
asks you for the programmer or plug in
the programmer
that's what that means this process what
we're going to do is we're going to test
a key we're going to make sure this key
is working and we're going to make sure
that the key is functioning
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to select that programmer
icon
on the main screen whenever we do that
it's going to take us to this screen is
automatically going to update this
programmer
every time we select programmer on the
icon it's going to automatically do that
update so we're always making sure that
we have
matching software in the tool and in the
programmer
once we've done that update you're going
to see the option for
testing of keys to do chip
ee prom or just to get the version
information out of that tool
sometimes if you have to call tech
support they'll ask you what the version
information is to make sure that you're
on the current
update version to make sure we're all
talking the same language and all
on the same page so currently what we
want to do is we just want to test a key
i want to test this key to see if it's
even good it looks good
it looks pretty but isn't any good we
can select
key and once we select key it's going to
take us into
key read and write and key information
we're going to start with
key read and write i just want to read
this key i want to know more about it
what kind of key is
it we have some keys that look exactly
the same and if you don't know what the
fcc id
is you may not know what type of key
this is so we'll select
key read and write we'll stick that key
in that slot
and it will tell us pretty quickly what
kind of key this is
so this is a high tag 2 key okay that's
that's great to know but i need more i
need more information i need to know
what the key information is so we'll
select ok
and then we'll go to read key id i want
to know what the id
of this specific key is
so we'll select read key id it'll pull
that information out of the key and
there's our key id now
there's a couple different things that
we can use this key id for
because on some vehicles whenever we
look at them let's say a toyota
it'll tell us all the different key ids
in the key slots
and we can see okay i have a toyota key
and i have a key id
is it for this vehicle is it even
programmed to this vehicle
so we can go through we can compare the
key id that we have to the key ids that
are already programmed into the vehicle
so
we can use that for a couple of
different reasons or we can just make
sure that the key is actually
transmitting an id
and that the id is whole and there's no
issues with that
so let's go through an easy key
programming session we're going to do a
key programming session on this
chevy volt and i know i know you don't
have to have a tool
to do the key programming session on
chevy
but by golly it makes it easier and you
already got the tool so
let's use it right so we can do this
chevy volt and i'm going to make it
present like an all keys lost and if you
have an all keys lost
on a proximity key car you can't exactly
turn the ignition on
and if you can't turn the ignition on
you can't really do an automatic vin id
so if we're doing all keys lost on this
car we're going to manually select it so
we're going to select
gm and we're going to do a manual
selection
if you are way better at keys than i am
and you know exactly what kind of system
this is
you can do that you can select system
selection
and go right in and jump right in and
start the key programming session
a lot of times i don't know what these
systems are so i do manual selection
and manual selection means that we're
going to actually manually id the car
and we're going to let the tool do all
the hard work and all the hard thinking
so once we select manual selection we're
going to select
chevy and it's going to ask us where are
you
not where was the car built
because that can throw us way off where
are you
what area are you in so on this one i'm
in the good old u.s of a
so i'm going to select usa it's going to
ask us what okay
what are you working on this is a chevy
volt so we're going to select that and
then what year range and key
type so this one is a 2015 so we're
going to select 2014 with 2016
smart our first step is to read the pin
in this vehicle we need to have a pin
on these chevy cars to be able to
program the keys to them
so we're going to select read
immobilizer password and that is going
to get us the pin number
and we're going to jump right into
password reading
is the ignition switch on no
because there's no way to turn the
ignition switch on because i don't have
a key
if we just go ahead and select okay
it'll work us through this process it's
going to ask
a couple of questions it's going to read
the pin and bam there you go
there's your pin number 1392. beautiful
part about this tool
is you don't have to memorize that you
don't have to write it down
if you want to you can take a screenshot
and usually i do
to take a screenshot if you look down
here at the bottom there's a picture of
a scissors
on a box and that is how you take a
screenshot you just hold down
on that and it will click and it'll
capture your screen
and it'll save that into data manager on
your tool so
if you're like me and sometimes you get
distracted and you're going a bunch of
different directions
you can grab the screenshot so you don't
have to write down what the pin number
is but
do remember that the tool will store
your pin number for that session
so it'll automatically fill that later
on
we'll select ok and now it'll take us
back to our
main function menu we'll select keyless
system and this is a controller
area network for can network so we'll
select keyless system
and then we want to let's say we want to
know more about this car okay
how many keys are programmed to this car
how uh
how is this system set up we can find
that a couple different ways so if we
select
information that will take us into
information about this immobilizer
module and
data about it so we can see how many
keys are already programmed into this
car
we can see the vin number that is
programmed to this module and does it
match the
vin number that is in every other module
in this car
we can also see some calibration ids
vcmc
lots of information is going to be there
if you need it
if you just want to know how many keys
are there you can select number of smart
keys so we give you a lot of different
options when it comes to
getting information out of these
vehicles so in this one we're going to
select
all smart keys lost
and it's going to tell us what the next
step is so the next step is we need to
place a smart key
to be learned into the key slot and
we're going to give you some information
about where
that key slot possibly could be once you
push
ok it's going to oh look automatically
populate that pin directly into the tool
you didn't have to remember it didn't
have to write it down you didn't have to
write it on your arm with all the other
pin numbers you got going on
so a tool automatically saves that for
you
and now we go through a couple of
different steps we're going to follow
the directions of the
of the tool so it's going to configure
the system first
it's going to go through that 12 minute
wait and then it's going to tell you
what to do turn the key on ignition off
push this button twist that knob
turn the flashers on all that
information of how to is going to be
built into the tool so you don't have to
memorize that for every vehicle
it's going to tell you exactly what to
do right there on the tool
once it's all done it's going to tell
you that the current key is complete and
the matching is done
do you want to do another one yes or no
on this one
we can do two keys i can push yes and
it'll automatically go through that
process
and no more wait time so that was on a
chevy car and chevy's
they're pretty darn easy but i wanted to
show you the process
of how the tool takes you through that
step by step
so you can see exactly how that process
is going to happen but not every vehicle
is the same
so let's check out a toyota and see what
kind of information we can get
out of that vehicle so i have selected
on this one if you look down in the
bottom it says
toyota camry and i selected a smart key
one of the things that i love about this
tool and that can really help you
through this process
is looking for a button that says
relevant information
so whenever we select this relevant
information button
the autel tool is going to give you some
good data and some good information
we're going to tell you what the chip
number is in this car
we're going to talk about the key
frequency which is 315 and we're gonna
talk about what
type of key it is and i know a lot of
times you're going to know that
but sometimes there's options on the
tool
that we're not for sure which one to
select
and by selecting the relevant
information it's going to tell us hey
if you select this one you're selecting
a 128 bit h
key it's a 315 frequency it's a
proximity key and oh by the way this is
what the key looks like is this what you
want to do
if it's not that's not my key we can
back out of that and select
the other option so good information and
that relevant information
uh to be had so make sure you use that
whenever you're not sure about what
direction to go next
that will help guide you in that
step-by-step process
as we get into this vehicle a little bit
farther
you're going to see a button down here
in the bottom that says operate
guide and operate guide is going to give
us a lot of information
so we look on the main screen and it
says add smart key clear smart key
smart box reset learn ecu
synchronization backup of mobile
data and generate simulator key
what i i've never done a toyota before i
have no idea
what any of those mean well if we select
operate guide it's going to take us to a
hey
just so you know add smart key means
this function
serves to add a smart key if you want to
do a smart box reset
we're actually going to clear all the
information out of that smart box
and what is a generate simulator key
well this function
serves to use the apb112
to generate a key so we're going to tell
you definitions of all those things that
are on the previous screen
that you were just looking at but also
there are precautions
because if you don't tow toyota right
it can cause you some problems so we're
going to give you precautions we're also
going to give you step by steps hey
this is all the process we're going to
do through this vehicle are you
ready or do you have everything you need
so precautions on this specific
toyota if you add a smart key function
as execute estep must be completed
within a specific time
don't go grab a sandwich and come back
because it'll it'll wipe everything out
so there is time limits on this vehicle
what does it mean to synchronize the id
what does it mean to use
a generate simulator key and what are we
going to do with this eeprom data
so it's going to give us precautions
about this vehicle even before we do it
so if you're new to a vehicle
look for that operate guide because it's
going to give you a lot of information
about your next step
and what you're going to do in this
process so let's contrast that with
let's say a volkswagen because every
manufacturer does it different
if you thought that every manufacturer
is exactly the same you've not been
doing this very long
so every manufacturer is going to be
different so this
is uh volkswagen audi key programming
when we jump into a volkswagen audi car
there's smart mode manual mode expert
mode and advanced mode
so advanced mode is where we are going
to see
our mqb immobilizer 4
and mo4 and mqb
now these are the only functions in the
tool that are going to have a
pay-per-use
subscription fee uh the immobilizer in
four is ten dollars and mqb is 30 bucks
and these are all done via paypal
and it's not a per programming fee so if
you have an issue you have to pay for it
again it's not like a token don't think
of it that way
as long as you're in that vehicle and
you've already done your your one
payment via paypal
you can do that as many times you need
to be able to get this vehicle figured
out so
that is the only pay use in this tool
everything else is going to be unlimited
use as long as your tool is under update
contract
so that is the only time you would have
any pay functionality and that
again is done via paypal directly from
the tool quick and easy process you
don't need to buy any tokens or have any
tokens
on hand
so if we go back to the volkswagen main
page we can jump
into expert mode if we jump into expert
mode
it's going to give us a lot of
information about
the different types of systems anytime
this is covered up a little bit but
anytime you see dump
in the description that means you're
going to do an eeprom pull module out
so different styles of volkswagen
systems are all here in expert mode and
we named it expert mode because you know
exactly what you're jumping into if
you're not a volkswagen expert
you can go back and click smart mode and
let the tool do all the help
for you but i guess what i'm getting at
is the tool is very proficient when it
comes to volkswagen
it can do a lot of the volkswagen
information and the tool will actually
walk you through that process to do it
if a module is required to pull out it
will
show you what that module looks like and
it will tell you where that module is
located it will tell you if you have to
pin out all that module or do any
connections to that module
all that's going to be built directly
into the tool
getting information from the tool to a
printer
can also be very helpful we talked about
the the pre-scan postscan reports we
talked about printing reports but how
does that process
work so if you have a printer in your
shop or if you have a printer in your
van we're going to go through the
process to
set up that printer and what it looks
like to be able to use that printer
so the alltel printer setup is where we
can do our pre-scan post scans we can
actually print screen captures
uh remember what i was talking about
where you writing all your notes on the
palm of your hand or on your arm
we don't need to do that anymore we can
capture those and print those out
wirelessly it makes it such an easier
process
so to do this process you're going to
need a pc
and the tool will actually communicate
directly to that pc so if you have a pc
in your shop or in your van
and you leave that on in your tool and
that piece here on the same network
we can communicate from the tool to the
pc to the printer
and the reason we did that is because we
don't know all the printer drivers
and some printer drivers are not
compatible with an android tablet
so this gives us the ability to just
send it directly to a pc let the pc
interpret all those drivers and just
spit out the printer so what we're going
to do from our pc we're going to
auteltools.com support and downloads
and you're going to see this download
icon
for maxi pc suite
we'll download that pc suite onto
our pc and that will put a folder
onto our start menu
so we go in and select that start menu
and go to the autel folder it's going to
give us a drop down
and you're going to see pc link
now once you click pc link a whole lot
of nothing is going to happen
well a lot of nothing that you see
actually what that's going to do is
going to take that
and throw that printer icon down into
your status bar in the bottom right hand
corner of your windows pc
so you'll see if you go down that this
little printer icon is hanging out down
there and what that means is
i'm ready i'm ready to receive your
print
um and it's always ready to go
if you don't have that on it will not it
will not do anything so make sure that
printer icon automatically turns on
when your pc turns on so what is that
going to do it's actually going to send
a version of a pdf directly from your
im508
to your pc and that is going to show up
in your pc link if you select to auto
print it will automatically come out
your printer
if you select or if you deselect auto
print it'll actually come to your pc
in a pdf document that you can that you
can save
to your pc uh for later on use
so a lot of information a lot of
information about your im508
and i know i didn't get deep into the
key programming session
because the tool is actually going to
take you through that process
and every manufacturer is going to be
different so i recommend
just trying it go ahead and push some
buttons read that relevant information
look at that operate guide to get the
most information out of that tool
to know exactly what your next step is
so there are some accessories to the
im508 as well and the one that we talked
about the most
is the apb-112 and that's going to be
used for toyota
doing a key simulator i would recommend
that
as the main accessory that you would add
to this im508
so again thanks for joining me i
appreciate you for coming
i'm chad from all telediagnostics and
we'll see you next time